I watched one piece at
0.25x speed and noticed some incredible
Secrets the first thing I noticed is
that at the start of the show pirates
were drinking from beer mugs but these
were quietly changed to these Barrel
looking mugs this change was definitely
made so it doesn't look like the straw
hats were drinking alcohol since none of
them were of drinking age then when
kizaru was in his office we could see
these letters on the wall for around 1
second this text reads uncertain Justice
and it's the Justice type kizaru follows
since he never takes anything seriously
another small detail you probably missed
was on wano when Sanji awakened his
germa abilities during this scene his
eyebrows actually flipped to look just
like his siblings however this Last
Detail I noticed May reveal who will
become the next n v Admiral recently in
the anime we were introduced to this guy
called kuroma after analyzing his name I
noticed that it consists of a color and
an animal which is something we only saw
in Admirals names and he is also based
on a famous Japanese actor same as all
other admirals